hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video today I want to talk about
one of my favorite tools that I use to
run my business and is called crowd
booster and what it basically does is
allow me to figure out what times of day
I should tweet to be able to have the
highest impact with my audience so this
is my tools page and I'll just go and
search for crowd booster there it is now
this is a free tool which is always
great and it will analyze your Twitter
page as well as your Facebook page if
you have a facebook page that you use
there's a lot of analytics in here a lot
of it again is free the main thing that
I use it for I'll show you here is this
part here which shows you the schedule
that you should use to tweet out so if i
click why what it basically does is
analyzed when people are interacting
with your tweets that you send out so
you could be similar tweets all day long
but this will tell you when you can have
the maximum impact with your audience at
certain times of day so basically what
it does is show you every hour of the
day and shows you every day of the week
and it will show you by the size of the
circle one the best times to tweet are
so for me in general two and three
o'clock are really good times and then
eight nine are also pretty good in the
morning and then maybe seven and eleven
so what I do is I take this data and put
it into buffer which is a another free
tool that I've talked about in the
previous video which allows you to
schedule your tweets so I don't have to
go online at two and three o'clock every
day and send something out it's odd i
might be scheduled in advance through my
buffer so i can find out what the best
times are through crowd booster so I've
set up my buffer to go for seven eight
nine to three and 11 based on the data
that I've gotten from crowd booster so
this is the main reason why i use it but
there's a couple other tools you can use
it might be helpful as well you get a
lot of stats that tells you how many
people are following you how many people
family tweets you sent out mentions
retweets etc it'll show you a graph of
your top tweets it shows you how many
replies you get how many people you've
reach on some of your tweets
you can customize it by the timeline
that you want I don't really look at
that too much I use buffer sometimes for
my analytics but what I do use sometimes
is this section here recommendations I
used to look at this every day but now I
don't do it as often so the two types of
recommendations the first is people who
you might want to connect with so it
shows you influential users who have
recently followed your account and
basically what it does is give you an
opportunity to be able to follow them
back and to mention them if you want now
how they judge who an influential user
is is by their cloud score and
unfortunately right now at least cloud
seems to be easily manipulated so I
found a lot of people on this list that
I don't really want to connect with and
they may be spammer accounts so for that
reason I don't check this every day if
there was a better way to do this then I
might be on here more often but
basically I can look at these two people
and see who they are and if I want to
engage with them or not so this person
is the professor and dean at Columbia
University tech evangelist so you know
maybe somebody who I would want to
connect with and thank them for
following me and this person is a nature
lover and social worker you know I'll
have the check maybe a little bit more
to see what she's into before I want to
interact with her so you can see you'll
see a list of people who are i believe
it's over 60 maybe over 50 and clout so
influential people and gives you an
opportunity to connect with them and
thank them for following you so that
could be a good way to start connect
with some of your influential followers
the next thing that they show here is
they show you tweets of people who have
mentioned you who you haven't written
back to now I don't really use this at
all I use HootSuite to manage the people
who connect with me so these are going
to be mostly spammers so somebody was
asked me to follow them back someone's
promoting a samsung computer or whatever
it is so I don't use this for this but
you can it's a free tool again so you
can see people who you need to connect
with who talked about you mentioned you
and
asking to get back in touch with them so
that's a cool way to you know be able to
manage your Twitter account again the
main reason I use it is to set my
schedule and I take that and put it into
my buff wrap and sometimes I'll use the
the recommendations here of influential
people just to see who's following me
and who I should thank for following and
maybe getting in touch with them you can
also integrate your Facebook page maybe
topic for a different day I don't use it
too much but again gives you lots of
stats on who's on your Facebook page who
you want to recognize your top friends
etc so there's a lot more stats here
again follow growth influential
followers opry tweeters that you can
dive into if you like you want more
detailed analytics on your Twitter
account and again it's all free so you
might as well go check it out so
hopefully you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please give it a thumbs up I'd
also love to hear your comments on what
you thought about it what tools you use
the comment that you guys leave really
helped drive all the future videos that
I make so I really appreciate them when
you do leave them and I try to write
back everybody so if you did please
leave a comment give that thumbs up and
we'll see you on the next episode
you